sei mesi fa all'inizio dell'anno a uno
dei più famosi e quotati ospedali
americani succede questo
un piccolo messaggio sul loro sito web
che dice abbiamo un problema
abbiamo un virus e non siamo più in
grado di fornire una serie di servizi
scusateci non era un virus e non è un
caso isolato
pochi giorni dopo in un altro ospedale
succede questo allora andato peggio
hanno pagato 17 mila dollari per avere
di nuovo i propri sistemi in funzione e
qualche giorno dopo è successo questo e
due settimane fa è successo questo che
sta succedendo
qualcuno inizia a chieder sono articoli
scientifici che iniziano a domandarsi su
questa epidemia di attacchi agli
ospedali alcune riviste mainstream che
se ne accorgono e addirittura il mit
massachusetts institute of technology
che fa uno studio scientifico
sull'aumentato rischio dei pazienti
negli ospedali a causa degli attacchi di
ransomware con la minaccia tramite la
quale criminali bloccano i sistemi a
un'organizzazione chiedo alla riscatto
nel caso degli ospedali questo può voler
dire la vita dei pazienti
non è il solo caso forse vi ricorderete
un anno e mezzo fa circa la chrysler ha
dovuto richiamare circa un milione e
mezzo di veicoli perché si era scoperto
che era possibile da remoto via
cellulare o poi vedremo
intervenire per esempio sui freni e far
frenare la macchina contro la volontà
del guidatore e ancora non è soltanto le
macchine perché notizie anche queste
abbastanza recenti le porte delle nostre
case quelle intelligenti che si aprono
con lo smartphone i sistemi di
riscaldamento delle nostre case gli
elettrodomestici smart la samsung ha
mandato in giro un comunicato proprio
utenti dicendo di fronte agli smart tv
quelli con la telecamera che riconoscano
i volti i gesti non parlate di cose
riservate perché non è detto che
rimangono in serate qualcuno potrebbe
sentire quello che è stato è di 100 i
frigoriferi che mandano le mail e
attenzione le telecamere di sorveglianza
quelle con cui ci accertiamo che le
nostre case non abbiano ospiti
indesiderati che sono state usate per
spiare nelle case degli altri tre 73.000
webcam a disposizione con il motore di
ricerca come google e potete andare a
vedere nelle case della gente che sta
succedendo
ecco che il mio mestiere occuparmi di
sicurezza dei sistemi delle
organizzazioni lo faccio da prima che ci
fosse internet
sicurezza significa protezione contro
chi ci vuole male
già perché qualcuno che ci vuole male
c'è sempre c'è anche adesso
adesso vi racconterò chi è che ci vuole
male quali sono i problemi di questo
meraviglioso e rutilante mondo
dell'internet delle cose gli oggetti
intelligenti connessi fra di loro e
connessi alla rete oggetti lampadine e
frigoriferi forni a microonde automobili
sistemi di controllo dei treni i sistemi
di controllo delle centrali di energia
tutto quanto si parla bello sicuramente
bello applicazioni fantastiche ma un
piccolo lato oscuro anche perché fra
questi oggetti che si parlano
c'è qualcosa di delicato oggetti che
trasmettono dati sulla nostra
con l'internet delle cose farsi male non
significa soltanto farsi rubare dei
soldi dal conto in banca ma significa
anche rischiare la vita che sta
succedendo perché succede questo bene
c'è un piccolo paese nell america del
sud
l'uruguay che insieme alla mauritania
gode nella proprietà di essere il paese
con il minor rischio sismico al mondo
a memoria d'uomo non c'è mai stato un
terremoto
gli ingegneri edili uruguaiani in teoria
potrebbero costruire delle case
bellissime senza avere la nozione di
ingegneria antisismica
perché non ci sono terremoti non hanno
mai avuto la necessità di fare case
antisismiche un ingegnere uruguaiano
bravo che fa case bellissime ma se si
trasferisce in giappone non funziona le
sue case non sono più adatte perché non
è che lui fa case fatte male che il
giappone è caratterizzato da un rischio
intrinseco che lui non conosce il
rischio di terremoto deve fare qualcosa
deve cambiare nuovo di fare case
dell'imparare possibilmente non dai
propri errori e imparare dall'esperienza
gli altri ecco noi siamo esattamente
nella stessa situazione con l'internet
delle cose non possiamo imparare dagli
errori dobbiamo imparare come si fanno
le cose fatte bene
dall'esperienza degli altri degli
ingegneri giapponesi che da tanti anni
combattono contro i terremoti del cyber
space che vuol dire sicurezza sicurezza
in realtà significa due cose in italia
non termina un po ambigua due
significati in inglese esistono due
significati cioè la safety e c'era
security la safety è la sicurezza di
questi oggetti gli oggetti che non ci
fanno del male e l'incolumità delle
persone oggetti che non ci recano danno
come i pacemaker che stanno lì belli
tranquilli impiantati e sono progettati
per essere soprattutto sicuri non
uccidere il paziente
poi c'è un altro aspetto la security che
è la cosa di cui mi occupo da tanti anni
york olin fanno il mio mestiere la
sicurezza delle reti e dei sistemi degli
oggetti connessi
gli oggetti che parlano per evitare che
qualcuno non autorizzato entry faccia
delle cose che non dovrebbe fare ecco
oggi questi due mondi purtroppo
convergono e la convergenza crea
problemi terrificanti perché da remoto
adesso si possono come dire taroccare
sabotare i pacemaker le pompe di
insulina oggetti che sono nati per
essere straordinariamente safe ma
assolutamente non s'è cure perché fino a
5 minuti fa su una scala del tempo
informatico non erano connessi in rete
come è successo tutto questo è successo
perché il nostro ingegnere uruguaiano
sapeva progettare case ma non conoscevo
i terremoti
facciamo conto di uno che progetta
automobili un certo giorno qualcuno gli
dà una bellissima centraline a
microprocessore che fico che ci faction
beh mi serve per comandare la biesse ho
bisogno di fare calcoli per gestire la
biesse devo misurare la velocità delle
ruote fare una sede i costi e quindi lo
gestisco con questa centralina ingegnere
che lavora per l'efficienza dice già che
c'è questa centralina un bell micro
professore sempre più lento
facciamoci dare qualche altra cosa bene
lo collego con una sonda al motore e
alla sonda lambda della marmitta
catalitica così ottimizziamo le
prestazioni e riducendo i consumi
perfetto e poi beh ci attacchiamo i
controlli di attitudine della macchina
senza di posizione e rollio imbardata in
modo che cosi ottimizziamo il sistema di
controllo dei freni dell'anti ski ed
esce per cedere fighissimo e poi
temperatura della macchina luce di
cortesia sistemi di comfort bene e poi
beh sistema di entertainment autoradio
telefono telefono no
il telefono parla fuori e se c'è
qualcosa che parla fuori può anche far
entrare a qualcuno che da fuori ecco
come si bloccano gli abs delle chrysler
utilizzando il sistema entertainment e
la macchina è collegato in modo diciamo
poco prudente in modo un po naif a una
rete esterna che poi sia cellulare
bluetooth wifi non importa abbiamo
aperto la porta un mondo che prima era
isolato adesso parla è questo il
problema
la realtà è che se non facciamo
attenzione tutti gli oggetti sono
vulnerabili a qualcosa che può entrare
da fuori
e siccome gli oggetti sono connessi
tutti con tutti
si aprono un sacco di rischi perché
purtroppo il male esiste i cattivi ci
sono non questi attenzione questo è
nell'immaginario collettivo gli hacker
anonymous non solo loro necessariamente
cattivi i cattivi sono altri anche se fa
comodo dare agli hacker la colpa di un
sacco di cose che succedono avrete visto
sicuramente nei giorni scorsi dare la
colpa agli hacker russi di un sacco di
brutte cose che stanno succedendo ma
questa è politica questa è propaganda
non importa problema che ci sono dei
cattivi veri la criminalità la
criminalità organizzata che è sempre
brava è sempre un passo avanti e buoni
per che studiano perché si organizzano
perché fanno soldi e la criminalità ha
già imparato a fare ricatti bloccare i
computer delle aziende chiedendo soldi
in riscatto ma ci sono altri cattivi che
ci preoccupano ancora di più prima delle
11 settembre nessuno avrebbe potuto
pensare che qualcuno avrebbe preso due
aeroplani pieni di gente avrebbe tirati
su dei palazzi di civile abitazione è
successo il mondo è cambiato adesso
dobbiamo ragionare purtroppo chi fa il
mio mestiere deve occuparsi di cose
brutte e tristi ma non possiamo fare
finta
che non ci siano ragionare anche che
succede se questi signori capiscono che
si fa terrore non soltanto entrando in
un ristorante una discoteca e sparando
con kalashnikov alla gente ma spegnendo
i pacemaker delle persone che stanno al
cinema o al giubileo o in metropolitana
e attenzione il problema è un po
ovviamente dei progettisti di chi decide
ricorderete questo caso
l'aereo germanwings il pilota in crisi
depressiva che decide di suicidarsi e
con l'occasione uscire tutti i
passeggeri del volo schiantandosi sulla
montagna sfruttando ironia della sorte
un meccanismo di sicurezza quello che
avrebbe impedito a un terrorista di
entrare nella cabina di comando di
pilotaggio per dirottare l'aereo una
porta blindata la cui apertura avviene
solo ed esclusivamente dall'interno
peccato che in quel momento all'interno
c'era solo lui
ecco in seguito a questo incidente agli
studi che sono stati fatti per evitare
cosa del genere in futuro qualcuno ha
avuto la brillante pensato di dire bene
dotiamo gli aerei di un sistema di
telecomando telecontrollo in modo che se
il pilota impazzisce da terra qualcuno
può prende il controllo dell'aereo farlo
atterrare
ecco questa cosa mi fa venire la pelle
d'oca
apriamo tutti gli aerei del mondo ha la
possibilità di essere telecomandati da
qualcuno che non è il pilota vi rendete
conto che una follia vero ma perché
cominciato a pensare come gli ingegneri
giapponesi quello che ha pensato questa
cosa l'ingegnere uruguaiano che non
pensa che ci siano i cattivi che non
pensa che ci siano i terremoti
purtroppo queste cose succedono
quotidianamente e tecnologie belle furbe
intelligenti vengono adoperate nel modo
sbagliato per ingenuità del progettista
che non conosce i rischi ma non possiamo
imparare dai nostri errori perché qui ci
facciamo male dobbiamo imparare dagli
errori fatti in altri settori
in anni precedenti
che cosa significa certamente non questo
questi sono gli amici
una popolazione felice e tranquilla ha
rifiutato la tecnologia usano i calessi
riscaldano le cose col fuoco vivono
benissimo
no non è questo il modo giusto la
tecnologia è utile serve è importante
internet delle cose è straordinariamente
importante per la crescita sociale va ad
operato bene i progettisti non fare il
loro mestiere informandosi magari un po
di più
di che cosa noi miseri informatici
abbiamo imparato in tanti anni di
combattimento contro i criminali gli
hacker e eccetera ma anche voi potete
fare la differenza perché la principale
misura di difesa è il comportamento
corretto e la consapevolezza è bello
attaccare il forno a microonde a
internet così manda una e mail al
supermercato e compra le cose necessarie
per fare la ricetta poi magari lo
controllo da remoto col telefonino con
lo stesso telefonino con cui controllo
il mio conto in banca oppure qualche
altra cosa o sguardo lo stato del delle
mie analisi
eccolo non va bene
utilizziamo un pochino più di buon senso
così come nessuno lascia casa aperta
perché sa che ci sono i ladri o nessuno
guida come un pazzo solo perché in
macchina c'è la biesse la prima misura
di difesa siamo noi con il nostro
comportamento con la nostra
consapevolezza quindi se volete
attaccare il telefonino al forno
microonde fatelo ma prima pensateci e
domandatevi è davvero una buona idea
grazie